HEEEY!!!
All right guys my name is Tom and let's get right to it!
Today I'm going to be talking to you guys about physical attractiveness.
Physical attractiveness seems to play a big role in our everyday lives, as shown by multiple studies.
These studies show that people who are considered physically attractive are attributed with more...
appealing qualities and traits. Attractive people are seen as smart,
sociable,
and they have a good moral compass.
Now while there have been studies that do substantiate the stereotype, should we believe it?
Attractiveness has influence in various areas of our lives, one being in the decision to hire. In this scenario
attractive people are more preferred over less good-looking persons even if they're more qualified.
What?
WHAT?!
W U T ?!1?
The Meta analysis (done by Lengua in 2000) shows that sixty-eight percent of attractive adults are
above the mean when it comes to occupational success, including income. Obviously, this is not
always the case. It can help women when applying for lower level positions
but not for higher ones, in the study done by Diff boy,
Marvel and Green in the late 70s and 80s
Ready for this? If a good-looking individual has committed a crime, their physical attractiveness
may influence judgments based on how serious the crime was.
Doesn't that just put more faith in your judgment system, America?
Yeah...! Researchers have found that
attractive males are twice as likely to avoid going to prison, as if they were unattractive
Now, to wrap it all up for you guys, being attractive can have positive effects as well as make someone seem
untrustworthy, and, you know, the whole
Crime thing that is serious because they're just pretty good looking...
Now, most of these studies have only been done in western countries, so we can't say it's
the same all around the world, and even so, how do we decide who is attractive?
What are the deciding factor?
Alright, guys, that's it for this episode! Be sure to check back for more awesome videos with Moi,
and comment what you think makes somewhat attractive! For me, it's the man scruff on the face...
Don't forget to give this video a thumbs up and subscribe!
We're going to be making- we're going to be making A BUNCH more videos about things like this and like psych stuff,
It's Gonna be so freakin awesome!
And please check the description box for links to the website and more articles that are just literally
mind-blowing, like, I never imagined any this could be even possible or true
while I was reading after I was done reading it was so awesome. Alright, love you guys! See you soon, BYE!